this actually isn't really a question
it's more of a comment yeah I kind of
turned it into a question right yeah
yeah you responded to the comment
lookalike yeah sure anyway coming Zeus
just want to say quick thanks I struggle
with the daily grind trading days for
dollars but you help me make it happen
yeah and my comment was like okay well
thank you I guess because I hope at the
same time that you're grinding that
you're trading that you're I hope that
you're not trading days for dollars long
term because long term that's a losing
proposition right if you're grinding and
it's not doing something you want to do
if it's a grind that you can't embrace
then you gotta find a way out of that
right you gotta find you can't tray you
don't want to trade days for dollars
because dollars don't mean anything days
all you got so you got to find a way out
now this does not mean you need to be
rash about it
this doesn't mean tomorrow you walk you
know go through this job anymore I'm out
and now you're broke no don't be rash
and don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater but do come up with a
long-term plan about what you want to do
how you want to do it where you want to
do it and this might take one year or
two years or five years it might take
five years to get to where you want to
be that's okay
that's fine it's it's actually kind of
cool when you're grinding right now cuz
you know there's something that you're
working towards in the long run that's
actually awesome so but but you gotta
have an exit strategy
you gotta have an exit strategy you've
got a plan and figure out how much money
it's gonna take and what are you gonna
do you're gonna work two jobs I'm gonna
save all my money right now I'm gonna
invest here you pay off my mortgage
whatever is you're gonna do so that you
can get yourself in a position where you
actually enjoy doing what you're doing
that's what you want and the one other
cool thing about this like like I say
man it's cool to grind and that
what we're here to do you're here doing
stuff right you're not doing anything
well then what are you doing so the
other thing that's cool though about
grinding and working is is that when you
get that freedom right that you work
hard for it's gonna be so much more
worth it
the discipline that you put into place
to get to that freedom that you want it
makes that freedom so much more worth it
so I appreciate it I'm glad you're
grinding I'm glad you're grinding hard
but don't just make that trade it's not
a square trade days for dollars not a
square trade get it back under your
control and we've had I've actually had
some really cool feedback on the podcast
of people that have hit me up and said
hey hi you told me to plan an exit
strategy I wish I could find this a guy
said you told me to plan an exit
strategy he's like that was whatever
nine months ago I saved my money I just
did this now I'm in another business I'm
kicking ass thank you right so it can be
done it's one of the things about cool
about being a human being you got free
will you can make stuff happen yeah so
go make it happen